oh can you hear me now
um
okay yes you're audible I'm sorry I
thought you guys can hear me so I
actually have myself manually muted on
my
it's okay okay uh so folks we'll be
starting the session in a few minutes on
time uh so meanwhile uh what you can do
is you can introduce yourself and chat
here so I am Russia I'm your host for
today's webinar and I'm joining from
Bangalore India I would love to know
where are you joining from
so this is a very good way to network
you know just before the event starts uh
go to network folks from around the
world and uh came to know each other
better
you can see my message on chat here so
I'm Johnny from India
and I would love to know where are you
joining from
I can see a keyboard has joined from
Malaysia
brother the folks uh will start the
session on time uh thank you for joining
early
so today we'll be talking about data
analytics boot camp by garlic how we can
embark on this journey and they will be
taking you through the career
information session and we have already
have a speaker Jeremy here with us so uh
I can see the introductions coming in on
chat
I can see
folks joining from Philippines Nigeria
or vacancy box of joint drum Arizona
Malaysia so on welcome welcome folks so
we are joined in early we're just
starting in few minutes on time
meanwhile what you can do is you can
just introduce yourself and chat here
keep the introductions coming and I can
see a lot of folks are introducing
themselves on chat
I can see managing also joining from
Nigeria
I can see
someone from Equity or Israeli
uh there's no disturbance from my
Android my voice is clear right
yeah you're coming through loud and
clear for me anyway okay awesome
so we'll be starting the career
information session on data analytics
boot camp how you can embark on this
journey with character Alex bootcamp in
few minutes meanwhile we can just do a
quick round of introduction so I'm
sharing here
I would love to know where are you
joining from
I can see a rod from Scott's Valley
hey hi
welcome welcome to the session uh thank
you for joining in early we will be
starting in few minutes meanwhile let's
get settled in wherever you are wherever
you're joining from uh also just giving
your advantage if just before we are
starting meanwhile other folks are
joining in uh so uh to get your question
answered anything related to data
analytics uh character analytics boot
camp uh if you have a question for
Jeremy our speaker today you can always
go and put on your questions for Q in
your box so I will be taking those
questions from the Q a box
I hope you understand
so
um I just have a question just go and
put down in the Q a box and I'll make
sure that your machine is answered uh we
would love to help you out anything
related to details uh career and also
what the caltex details
I can see more introductions coming and
I can see the Sean Health Center of Sri
Lanka I can see Dan joining football
Bank
uh so we're just doing quick round of
introductions where are we joining from
on chart so
good luck to know where are you joining
from before we start
humans
I can see from Pittsburgh uh hey hi I
hope I'm pronouncing your name right
please correct me
also folks will be starting the session
in few minutes
uh we are just getting centered again we
will be just doing a quick round of
Productions on chat here
I can see uh sometimes joined from this
book
I would love to hear your name as well I
cannot uh we got here on YouTube
uh so if you uh have a question related
to data analytics boot camp by Caltech
or anything in general uh information in
terms of career uh built into Data
ethics uh please do go and put on your
questions in the Q a box we'll be having
a special session for the Q a towards
the end of the session and also try to
take few questions you know during the
webinar as well so uh just help me out
by putting down those questions in the Q
a box during the session if you have any
questions feel free to ask
I think uh let's start with a few ground
rules so we
already joined us and also the session
has been recorded So if you want to go
through the webinar again immediately
you can also go through it you can
expect a follow-up email with the
recording links offer so uh in case
you're putting on questions on chat I'm
so sorry we might miss it so please do
put down your questions on the Q a box
whenever you have a question you can
find the Q a box on your screen very
easy you can just go and put down your
questions there and make sure that your
questions get the answer
now uh coming back to the agenda uh we
will be obviously getting to know more
about you uh so just to understand how
we can help you out uh with this career
information session on read analytics
boot camp by caltic and we'll be talking
about data analytics careers and also
how Caltech cpme prepares you and gets
you job ready uh course the
certification as well uh poster will be
taking you through the enrollment steps
and also the bonus offer and also there
will be a special duration for the Q a
part so again like mentioning that
please do put down your question in the
queue in your boss so uh we'll make sure
that your queries get answer related to
any video data ethics and uh this course
so let's start by getting to know you a
little better in order to help you
better uh so how much experience do you
have you can see a quick poll on your
screen uh if you're currently studying
you can choose the first option if you
are basically a fresher just started off
you can select the second one zero took
years of experience if you have three to
five years of experience you can select
the third one if you have more than five
weeks of experience you can select the
fourth one
so would love to know how much
experience do you have
so please choose the suitable option as
per your experience this way we will uh
understand basically how we can help you
or better so I can see the post moving
in we have gotten a great active
audience here so most of the folks have
already voted so that's great
so few of the folks who have not voted
uh I'll be closing the poll in 15
seconds so you can quickly go and just
choose the option suitable for you
there's a quick poll on your screen uh
so how much years of experience do you
have
you can just select an option and submit
it
we'll give it 10 more seconds
okay I didn't see the poles still moving
uh okay I can see the bus moving still
so three of the folks who have not voted
yet so would love to know how much years
of experience do you have
okay I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds
so five four
three two one
thank you so much for sharing uh and as
you can see that uh after folks are
currently studying more than a lesson of
the folks and we can see uh Premier
members of the folks have three to three
years of experience uh we can see few
with three to five years of experience
and we can see a few of them with more
than five years of experience so that's
great thank you so much
now uh coming back to uh our speaker
today uh tell me uh will be taking us
through the data analytics boot camp by
Caltech uh would you like to give us
your introduction is that I mean
uh sure so uh good morning everybody
Jeremy Samuelson
um
I've been uh a data scientist and
machine learning engineer in industry
for a little over 15 years now
um I have mostly been a consultant
actually so I've worked with various
consulting firms right now I'm Chief
data scientist at Road Data Solutions
um
my primary client slash project kind of
has me actually embedded within Equifax
Where We Are
working very very hard to take a data
driven and kind of machine learning
driven approach to detecting identity
fraud and payment fraud as well so uh
basically all kinds of
different uh kinds of
patterns of behavior in a person's say
digital identity which all of us have
that would kind of reveal to us that
there may be some some things that are
not quite above board going on
essentially so uh yep that's me
thank you so much for introduction uh
and uh yeah looking forward to the
session so let's start uh so uh this
pose is powered by Sabrina we are known
as the world's number one bootcamp uh
also we are very proud to train over 5
million plus Professionals in over 450
plus countries also we have been in the
digital space for almost 13 years so and
we are very very proud of transforming
lives in a little space over these uh
years past few years so thank you so
much for joining we'll be starting this
session now so we'll be talking about
careers in data analytics
can you tell us how data has become so
essential in today's decision economy
yeah absolutely
um
so
basically today we have
so many data sources available that
generate so many data and what this
actually allows us to do is essentially
apply the scientific method to actual
business processes so if you look at
consulting or how businesses were
managed in previous decades uh and we're
a lot of hunches right there were a lot
of things that kind of sounded
heuristically like they would make sense
or like they would be good uh some of
these ideas were pretty good some of
these ideas uh were ultimately not and
so what this Advent of these sort of
like data age uh has allowed is we can
sort of weed out uh what ideas are
profitable and good and should be you
know pursued and developed and what
ideas uh are not really worth pursuing
or actually going to get the company
into trouble so a quick anecdote about
that is uh very early on in my career
had a Consulting engagement at a
hospital
and actually the first kind of question
that was brought to me was one of the
hospital administrators came to me
and said I think we're losing a lot of
money I think that uh you know basically
we're having patience uh you know
because patients have a choice of where
they receive care and they're choosing
to receive care elsewhere and so our
doctors are actually seeing patients at
other hospitals and I think we're losing
a lot of money that way like basically a
lot of kind of like lost revenue or
foregone Revenue
um excuse me and he said I would like
very much
to convince the rest of administration
that we need to really solve this
problem and I need to figure out what
would do it so we I think we could
probably throw about 10 million dollars
at this problem uh but I need to know
what it would take like would it be uh
do we need a nicer doctor's Lounge uh
like is there some Avenue for us to kind
of like give some kind of like Kickback
or whatever almost like a commission to
like doctors who see patients at our
Hospital like what would that take right
um this was also my first Consulting
engagement at a hospital so I actually
didn't know at the time how like
physician accreditation actually worked
at institutions like hospitals so I was
kind of like yeah I'll look into it and
I was like do you have any data and he
said no which is actually quite often
the answer to that question uh so
ultimately it did some research
found a data set with the American
Healthcare Association or the ahca which
uh we were able to go back for two years
we had to purchase the data so we
purchased two years worth of data that
showed us every procedure that was done
in this area where this Hospital serves
uh no pii about patients but basically
like who was the physician uh where you
know where was the facility where this
was done
um what was the actual procedure that
was done like what's the doctor
specialty like all these different
things
so the first thing I actually asked
myself was
um how big of a problem is this I mean
this guy
says he wants to throw 10 million
dollars at solving this problem but I
mean is it that big of a problem maybe
it's a really huge problem maybe it's
not it's 10 million dollars even an
appropriate number so I wanted to find
out like how much is this really
happening like how much are Physicians
even seeing patients at multiple
hospitals
uh it turns out almost none of them
so it turns out about like 97-ish
percent of all Physicians only ever
perform procedures at One hospital they
only ever show up at one facility
basically and then when you look at the
very few Physicians who did show up at
multiple facilities it was like
um Baptist south Baptist beaches you
know it was like this one physician
showing up at basically all these
hospitals that are like obviously in
network together
um and so then once you kind of like
kind of enrich the data with this column
about the network that the facility
belongs to and then aggregate to that
level you find that actually no
Physicians show up in more than one
network at all so this guy basically
wanted me to come up with an analysis
that would convince Administration to
spend 10 million dollars on this problem
around solving this problem that the
data showed they ultimately don't have
so uh in a bygone era that would have uh
that would have just led to them
spending 10 million dollars to solve
this problem we would have just assumed
like well hey this administrator says we
have this problem let's spend 10 million
dollars fixing it
um but with data and data analytics we
were able to actually kind of treat that
like a hypothesis and basically go back
into the data and see like is this
hypothesis actually born out right like
is there do we actually see what we
would expect to see if this hypothesis
were true and in that case the the win
was that we saved the hospital from
spending 10 million dollars on a problem
that they don't have
well that's that's really
that's real much for sharing that also
we'll be talking about uh what
up-to-date skills we need basically to
get data analyst uh do you mean how does
this course ensure that Learners are
equipped with the latest data and gives
students needed in practice
can you guys hear me I actually can't
remember which way is mute
okay okay good good yeah yeah so um yeah
this actually looks really good so
um yeah python uh there's actually quite
a bit of work that's done in Excel
actually exciting thing I don't know if
you guys saw this it was announced I
think it was either last week or the
week before that actually python is now
integrated into Excel so you can
actually write python code inside of an
Excel workbook very cool
um AWS actually any kind of cloud
platform so like Azure uh Google Cloud
platform any of those uh Tableau always
popular yep and then basically any any
kind of data manipulation analytics like
reporting all that stuff and I love that
we have linear and logistic regression
on there because
I think a lot of people kind of dismiss
these as like very
um
I don't know basic models or whatever
but truly linear and logistic regression
are kind of like Workhorse algorithms
that we use all the time uh so yeah
these are absolutely essential
um so and actually little spoiler alert
for those of you who do sign up for the
the boot camp uh if you're excited at
all about uh deep learning and deep
neural networks it turns out that
actually the basis uh in terms of theory
for those is actually linear and
logistic regression they're actually the
neural networks are almost like an
expansion of these models uh so you know
so they definitely should not be
dismissed they're definitely very
important
oh well that's good that's awesome like
I
have a question
uh on the creative also maybe we can
take that up uh what practical skills do
you think participants will gain from
your data analytics boot camp how do you
ensure they are well prepared for real
world challenges
uh yeah it's an excellent question so uh
we do actually uh have
like Theory discussions right where we
go through slide decks or
um I'll even
you know have like a thing that Clips to
my desk and has this arm that kind of
mounts like you know an iPad that's
looking down at my desk so that you can
see like notes because a whiteboard's
kind of not very tenable in this kind of
class setting so something that you know
basically is like a good uh serviceable
uh substitute for that so we do have
these Theory discussions which are very
very important but we also do have uh a
Hands-On uh cloud-based Jupiter
uh kind of environment
where we can code stuff up in Python and
R and other languages that we actually
don't use quite as often like Julia so
you actually will get uh some real
programming
um
you know hands-on experience as well as
demonstrations in fact I think later I'm
going to walk you guys through like what
the learning management system looks
like uh if you want I can even show you
like a notebook uh that I coded up with
my class
just last week to show you guys like
what that would look like uh so yeah
there's there's a lot of uh actual kind
of uh you know hands-on experience with
you know actual data sets uh you know
coding up actual models from scratch but
then also uh experience of what that
looks like in terms of like
state-of-the-art tools that are used all
over the place today in Industry so yeah
you really do get all of that exposure
to all of that in the boot camp
uh I think one more question what are
the challenges of data analytics in the
real world
uh so broadly this may not be a very
satisfying answer but it's the right
answer it's the real real answer the
real challenge of data analytics and
data science in the real world is the
data
unfortunately uh that uh you know there
are all kinds of things that you kind of
like imagine you might do right the you
know kind all kinds of like important
features that you would like to be able
to engineer in the data for your model
or things like that but
um
often the challenge is either getting
your hands on the data in the first
place
uh so I've had plenty of uh things that
we've wanted to do for a client or that
a client has wanted to do but the data
set simply doesn't exist uh we've had
situations where the data does exist but
is basically owned by some kind of
gatekeeper that would charge us an
exorbitant amount of money to get the
data and so it becomes kind of
economically and feasible to pay for the
data
um I think of a few examples that we can
go into if you guys are curious about
that and then assuming you can actually
get the data then
um yeah there's often the question of
like well we have multiple data sources
that we have to pull together can we do
that effectively and you know in a way
that everything's still
you know make sense and it's going to
work once it's all together
or does this actually have all the
things that we need in it
uh sometimes you have to contend with
things like there are a lot of the you
know observations here that are missing
and so you know do we actually have
enough complete cases that we you know
could do something effective with this
you also have to ask yourself like why
would data be missing like how do we
handle that effectively because if you
just throw out all of your incomplete
cases if there's actually some
propensity for missingness that's
correlated with your other variables you
actually may bias your model or your
analysis entirely by throwing out
incomplete cases
um so you have to think very very
carefully about how to deal with that
effectively uh so yeah like I would say
always always always the challenge is uh
getting your hands on enough data that
is high quality enough to actually
execute the thing that you'd like to
execute
so uh thank you so much for answering
that question I hope that you know uh
also let's move on
to the most important part uh the salary
part so uh basically what kind of growth
uh can Learners expect after taking up
this data analytics bootcamp caused by
cardiac uh I as we can see that by 2026
uh you know from from uh Glassdoor shows
that 28 of annual job growth will be
seen so as we can see that for a data
analyze the uh basically the minimum
salary is of 56k dollars and we can see
the maximum is well almost approx one
one lakh dollars and also for a senior
data analyst also uh we can see a
similar range of salary as well uh
leading into the higher range so um how
basically does uh taking up data risk
scores can boost their salary wage as
well you know what what kind of
expectation they can come from when
they're taking up this course as well
are you asking sorry were you asking me
that yes
oh yeah so um
yeah where uh
your salary is largely tied to what
you're capable of doing it's tied to
some other things as well like your
level of education completed and
um you know a number of years of
experience that you have what kind of
track record have you demonstrated with
previous employers that kind of stuff
but ultimately
um
you know it kind of comes down to
what do you know what can you get done
uh for your clients or for your employer
so uh yeah attending a program like this
boot camp is basically designed to give
you all of that uh real world practical
Hands-On knowledge that would you know
put you in a very you know very strong
position to go in and command a higher
salary
um and especially if you completed and
get the certificate I mean the
certificate that you would get is like
from the California Institute of
Technology which is a highly recognized
you know highly accredited institution
uh that I think would be recognized
basically all over the world uh
certainly all over the US uh so yeah
there's there's also that you know you
kind of have that behind you as well
that you could add to your resume or
your LinkedIn profile or whatever once
you're done
uh but that sounds nice thank you so
much for explaining that now
the examples of companies which are
hiring so you can see Amazon Google
companies which are hiring and also uh
we have talked about the skills you have
talked about the salary we have talked
about the career Parts you can take up
uh what exactly is stopping you from
taking up uh this data analytics uh
course so you can see a quick call on
the screen
foreign
we may have actually lost her for just a
moment
foreign
if you feel like I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become uh
job ready in this field uh the third one
is I find it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos the fourth one is my
work schedule won't allow me enough time
for learning so choose the option which
is the most suitable for you as per the
concern you have in terms of getting
certified in legal links and also taking
up this course by details down by Canada
so I'll be giving 50 seconds more I can
see the poles are still moving in most
of the folks have already selected
what's exactly stopping them from taking
up this uh data on this boot camp
so help help us out and let us know what
is your biggest concern so we can help
your pattern
okay I'll be giving it 10 seconds more
so only few of the corks are not yet
voted you can just go and share your
biggest concern you have uh when you
want to take up this boot camp for this
like I think
so what is the biggest concern
so I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds so
five four three two one
let me share the results
uh so as we can see that the biggest
concern here are basically promoting
there's a tie and I can find a fully
comprehensive curriculum and the second
one is I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
uh a few of them have voted for I find
it difficult to learn from greedy
products videos and uh you can see like
few words from my work schedule
so thank you so much for sharing so we
can see the biggest concern here now uh
we obviously have a program character
database program which actually gives
you that comprehensive and
industrialized learning part uh and this
being an ideal program where you get
access to integrated handsome latch and
you get to work on projects which will
be talking about uh in the coming
forward slides and also equal access to
online virtual classrooms and this is
basically flexible to fit your lifestyle
as well uh the Celtic guidance bootcamp
the nutrition of this program is only 6
once and you can just give uh 10 to 15
hours per week to basically complete
this program
so uh and the price for this is 8 000
USD
also at the end of all you will be
getting a Celtic CDMA boot camp
certification uh which you can see on
the screen here and also uh you'll be
working on captioning projects which you
can showcase on your portfolio also the
Catholic CDMA Circle membership where
you get to uh basically be a part of a
circle where you get to interact with
folks from our drivers Industries and
coming from diverse companies as well
and also from different parts of the
world as well so that's pretty
interesting and uh there have been
online convocation with caltex ctme and
simile uh which makes it pretty
interesting because in an offline
setting uh you usually like I think
invite your parents or your very closest
to family members or friends but here in
an online convocation uh all basically
all of your relatives or all of your
friends so far away can also attend your
online conversation so that makes it
very interesting and a very special uh
convocation to have by Karthik and
simple now and also you'll be getting
career assistance through simply nice
value which will be talking about um or
moving forward
uh now let's talk about the caltex cpma
advantage so uh like uh just want to
know like have you guys heard of caltex
before
would love to know and chat
like has anyone heard about Karthik uh
before
yes or no
okay I can see her yes
you know I can see Phil nose as well
coming in it's okay and we'll talk about
it okay you can see more yes is coming
in
okay okay awesome awesome uh so
basically uh Karthik
um California Institute of Technology is
a 130 year old institution uh but just a
very uh interesting fact that uh has
anyone heard about Big Bang Theory TV
series
okay uh so basically this one of the
very popular tvcs is based on calcic
because it has one of the world's best
scientists and uh Noble audience so uh
it basically is a home and I'm gonna
matter to many Noodle laureates and also
consistently ranks in the top five
universities worldwide uh all having
kinetic cdna on a CV will actually give
you recognized worldwide and will
actually boost your profile very well uh
now moving on uh to eligibility and
prerequisites so you don't have to have
a prior knowledge of programming or
technology uh our high school diploma or
equivalent at Italy city is a page will
be more than enough for joining us and
also you don't have to have a work
experience uh for this particular
program of data analytics so
um so let me just have a question uh
that uh not having a prior energy
programming or technology uh have you
seen students succeed when they are
digging up this characteristics boot
campus
um so I have seen students succeed
there's actually one in the cohort that
I'm teaching right now who came in with
no prior programming experience
whatsoever
um to level with you guys he did
struggle a bit
um to keep up with some of the some of
the material so you kind of do have to
be willing if you are coming in with no
prior background in uh you know
statistics probability uh some other
mathematical topics like
um calculus linear algebra uh and if you
have like no programming experience you
can still do it you absolutely could
still succeed but there will be some
extra work uh that you'll kind of need
to uh to put in to get yourself caught
up
uh very much to the student's credit
though he has done that
um so in addition to so my particular
cohort uh we teach or sorry I teach on
Saturdays and Sundays but then I also
offer office hours on Tuesdays and
Thursdays uh and this guy's there every
every Tuesday and Thursday uh in fact
quite often he's the only one who shows
up two office hours
but he actually does utilize every
opportunity to you know come in and have
me go over stuff with them uh so he's
actually picked it up very quickly
um and yeah now now I would say he's
right on par with basically anybody else
in the cohort
wow that's great and uh I can see one
question on uh the Q a box and maybe we
can take that up uh in real life
projects how do you collaborate with
stakeholders and you mean experts to
understand the requirements and align
your analysis with their goals
uh so that is let's see I'm trying to
find that one so I can read it uh
also we can take up this question maybe
in the
projects as well that's okay
um yeah so anyway how you align with
stakeholders so you do have to have
quite strong
uh communication skills right so you
have to be able to listen to the
stakeholder uh really kind of empathize
with the situation that they're in right
like what is sort of this like major
pain point for them uh you know kind of
within their business within their
operation whatever it is they're trying
to achieve
um
and uh sometimes it's like very broad it
kind of really depends on the
stakeholders sometimes they're just kind
of like you know you tell me like our
revenues down can you tell me why can
you help us figure out like what we
should do to change that
um
sometimes it gets like very very
granular and very very specific so like
right now
um
you know one of my primary stakeholders
at Equifax in terms of like the model
that I'm building for them uh that's
going to improve our identity fraud
detection for what we call new account
opening so as people apply for like new
loans or credit cards or things like
that
um this is more of a customer facing
thing but he's kind of like I really
really want the model to Output a score
right like a score from like zero to a
hundred of like how much do we suspect
like that this is that this is fraud
right so it's like okay that's fine so
like
um a very specific ask right and in that
case you know it just takes knowing
knowing how machine Learning Works
basically to know like how do you
structure the model so that that's what
it outputs
um so yeah basically it comes with a lot
of yeah a lot of listening a lot of
asking the right kinds of questions a
lot of documenting stuff like writing
things down so that uh you make sure
that you've caught all the important
bits uh that they're really kind of
after
um
yeah and I would say uh the other thing
too that most data scientists are
actually quite bad at uh and that I work
very very hard to not be bad at
is you want to actually present to your
stakeholders metrics that they actually
care about so
um in data science we get very nerdy
about stuff
um
you'll talk about like your your
Pearsons r squared or your Akai
information Criterion or your receiving
operator characteristic that we'll talk
about all these like really nerdy
metrics on model performance but the
truth is if you're ultimately talking to
like the CFO or the CTO of a company
they do not care about that at all
um ultimately what they want to know is
like well what was the impact of this
thing on the business
um and so you should actually very much
familiarize yourself with metrics that
they care about and figure out how to
tie what your model is doing to an
impact on that uh the one I would
recommend is called the ebitda which is
like the most awkward acronym in like
all of business uh but it stands for
earnings before interest uh taxes
depreciation uh and amortization so
basically it's like what is the overall
company performance before all of the
accounting Voodoo that's like out of
scope for us uh so if you could actually
go back
and I believe me I know this is like a
ton of work to do but it's totally worth
it uh so I had a very very large supply
chain client very recently
uh where we implemented a ton of
algorithms to either automate completely
or very much streamline certain
Warehouse operational processes and at
the end of all that I was able to go
back to their CIO and say
like we actually have measured that the
impact on your ebitda annually as a
result of this deployment is 82 million
dollars right so like he I could tell
him all day long about the all these
other nerdy metrics that he would have
just been like but he was definitely
excited to hear uh that there's been an
82 million dollar annual Improvement to
the bottom line of the company right so
like that's the kind of stuff that you
need to think about as well
oh thank you so much hope that answers
your question uh now moving on how this
program
uh so we'll be talking about how this
program builds your data skills step by
step uh is there anything you take us
through this steps uh how how exactly
this program will yes yes and also get
some job pretty as well
totally um
so yeah here at the bottom we see so
just an introduction session
uh for the data analytics bootcamp so
that very much is just kind of your
instructor uh well largely just be
getting a sense for what's your
background what level are you currently
at with different skills like
programming or software like Excel or
Tableau or things like that
um kind of where you know a bit of a
pressure check on like where you're at
with your your mathematics things like
that
um and then basically yeah once uh they
have a sense for that they can kind of
tailor uh the material for the students
going forward
um and then yeah you get into things
like Excel which is I think kind of the
dark matter of the analytics world uh so
you know probably the most widely widely
adopted or you know widely in use
Technologies even even today even in
um
even for things that are like
surprisingly sophisticated right so I
had a project with standard and Poor's
uh about 10 years ago a long time ago
um
where we were doing kind of like uh a
Regulatory Compliance thing for them uh
I was with Promontory Financial Group at
the time so the SEC posts the 2008
financial crisis actually requires
institutions ratings agencies like s p
uh to have their models validated by a
third party uh if you know anything
about the 2008 financial crash you'll
know exactly why that's needed uh so I
personally had to validate uh 300 models
that were actually designed or the the
purpose of these models was ultimately
to come up with like a credit rating for
bonds or a risk rating for bonds so like
if you've ever looked into that kind of
stuff before things like you know uh you
know a double a double A Plus Triple A
whatever like basically they have all
kinds of different
that look at all sorts of different
things that basically arrive at a
determination for that so
they were undergoing this SEC review
um our firm had to be the third party
that was going to validate all of these
models
and I was expecting to see a whole bunch
of stuff in Python going in I'm like
yeah I got 300 models I'm gonna have to
you know validate all this python stuff
and there were some in Python and there
were some in R but I would say actually
the ones that the thing that showed up
the most in that project was Excel there
were tons of models uh for Val for
basically um
uh what they ultimately predict is
called the dscr the debt surface
coverage ratio because if you issue
bonds you have like these monthly
payments called coupon payments and so
basically there are all these models
that kind of stress the project and
figure out like are there any
circumstances under which this company
would be like unable to meet their
obligation like were there any
circumstances where this company would
be unable to meet their coupon payments
um
and then you also kind of have to look
at other things too like well like how
bad does it get like how short of their
how big is the shortfall and How likely
is that to happen there are all these
different things that go into
that um so yeah interestingly uh at
least half of them
were built in Excel so Excel is huge
it's all over the place
uh yeah then they move on to
presentations which is Big because
all the you know Wonderful insightful
analytics in the world are
not very helpful ultimately if you can't
actually present them to people
so you're gonna have to work on that uh
then we get into kind of
um
what I would call sort of more low like
low-level technology so SQL uh which is
basically how we uh write structured
queries against relational databases uh
because actually
uh even though there are a lot of new
things that are emerging like graph
databases or document databases there
are all these like new kind of exciting
things
um for different kinds of data at
varying levels of structure but still
the vast majority of data today still
lives in relational databases so you do
need to know SQL to get that stuff
um yeah then python which
there were some like real I don't know
type moments for a while there I think
between like R and python but like
python has in the last five years
definitely emerged as sort of the
default or go-to language in data
science and analytics uh it just really
is
phenomenally powerful for all the stuff
that we needed to do so you'll be
learning about python
and specifically about kind of the
packages and libraries that we use in
the data science and analytics space so
that would include like the numpy stack
which includes numpy itself there's
actually just a numpy package uh pandas
which gives us access to data frames for
tabular data in Python
matplotlib which is how we actually make
visualizations in Python very very nice
Library
scipy which kind of has all the other
sciency stuff that numpy doesn't have
broadly
it's a gross oversimplification but you
know
um yeah and then into things like
scikit-learn which is very useful uh
tool for fitting uh machine learning
models to things and statistical models
and stuff like that uh I think
um stats models the stats models API is
also covered in that as well if I recall
uh again very very useful especially for
like time series modeling it's probably
where that shows up the most
uh yep and then we move up to data
visualization using Tableau uh so this
is actually often
how you will deliver analytical results
or modeling metrics or results even
to non-technical stakeholders is that
you can basically kind of pipe this
stuff directly in to Tableau and then
structure it in a dashboard or something
like that where you know
say you have a bunch of like customer
service metrics the customer service
manager can actually like log into
Tableau look at the dashboard that's
relevant to them look at all the kind of
like you know convenient pre-made kind
of data visualizations and the metrics
that they care about so Tableau is kind
of this like and they can even do some
tinkering themselves without using code
so really really great
uh yep and then we move up to data
analytics on AWS so like I said there
are actually multiple platforms for
cloud but um
definitely in my experience like 80
percent of my clients that are on the
cloud are on AWS it's like the biggest
one by by quite a good margin
um learning about analytics on AWS
and ultimately if you ever deploy
anything in your in your career uh it's
gonna be on the cloud uh it just is
these days uh so AWS is a great thing to
know a great tool to have in your
toolbox
and then finally
all that comes together in your uh boot
camp Capstone projects where you can
actually kind of like bring all of your
skill set to bear on a particular
business problem and data set and all
that and you can kind of you know
show yourself and anybody else that you
really do know how to do this stuff
so there you go
thank you so much for leading us through
the steps for uh exactly how this
program is this
uh we have one question here
um I haven't heard about machine
learning is that a major part of the
course see Daniel has asked
so
um
for the analytics boot camp if this is
actually the the boot camp that I teach
um yes very much uh we will cover
uh the basics of machine learning uh
again starting with things like linear
and logistic regression
we cover tree based models like decision
trees and random Forest
um we do cover other things like
perceptrons and support Vector machines
which are closely related to find out
how take the boot camp I guess
um and then ultimately we do get into
deep learning so
um extending linear and logistic
regression into into feed forward
artificial neural networks and then uh
the courses that I'm teaching also kind
of extend that into further Specialties
such as natural language processing or
NLP or computer vision uh so then we
obviously get into
other slightly more sophisticated neural
net architectures such as convolutional
neural Nets so we talk about like what
is convolution
how does it get incorporated into a
neural network why do we do that like
what does it actually do for us what is
it you know what capabilities does it
give the network that it wouldn't have
otherwise uh as we talk about all that
and then recurrent neural networks for
looking at sequences such as text or
even time series so we do talk about all
that stuff and I believe Russia you'll
have to
uh sanity check this but I believe
there's actually even some room within
the boot camp for some like elective
stuff is that correct yeah so so really
if that kind of stuff
uh interests you especially uh then you
basically kind of have room to pick that
up in an elective at some point in the
boot camp as well
yeah
um
it comes as a part of the program
um also moving forward we are getting a
lot of questions
on the Q a box so maybe let me just take
one question then maybe we can talk
about the tools and platforms as well so
I can see Pablo has asked the question
that predictive and prescriptive
analytics all done in python or or do we
use our other tools for that
um
so
yeah you will actually kind of talk
about that in
uh really any of these so like in
Tableau
um
uh if you take a particular kind of
focus in R what you can take as an
elective or there's even a particular as
far as I know kind of like focused boot
camp that goes more down the r path than
the python path you would obviously
learn how to do this stuff in R
um but yeah primarily we do cover that
kind of stuff in Python uh and that's a
feature not a bug uh I mean the reason
why we do mostly cover uh you know
python as the tool for that is because
in Industry that is uh the tool of
choice right so
um I mean that's just kind of what it
looks like even if someone hands you
something like an Excel file uh I'm just
gonna like be totally real with you guys
I never open stuff in Excel
even if someone ultimately sends me an
Excel file uh you can open it directly
in a in a data frame in Python and
that's kind of my preferred way to do it
and so that's like you know in any team
that I've been on
you're either using python or if you're
not using python you're probably using R
uh and that's going to be your kind of
like primary go-to for most of your
analysis and then
other tools like Tableau and stuff like
that
you certainly can use uh for more
analytical insights uh kind of easier
faster manipulation of some of the
things once you've prepped it for
for that environment but a lot of those
tools are actually mostly for
communicating your results to
non-technical stakeholders that don't
want to do code or can't do code so
um yeah so again into the sort of sum
all of that up yes most of it's in
Python uh but again that's that very
much reflects sort of the state of the
industry as well
and also moving on uh cash flow projects
which we have talked about earlier so uh
how does having a caption project on
your CV uh once you're done with a
certification uh gives you that
real-time project experience as well uh
plus boost your profile as well you know
when you're applying for jobs like uh
can you help us with that like how
exactly does it take uh you know I
learned having a caption project on this
week
Yeah so basically
um something like a degree is great but
uh ultimately someone who's considering
you for a job wants to see like well
what have you done like what like real
projects have you done
um if you've already had a job as a data
scientist or data analyst then that's
not too hard because you can just talk
to them about what you did at your last
job or for your last client or whatever
um but if you're new
you know if you're still a student today
or you have you know you've recently
graduated and you're looking for that
first job
um you may kind of find that sort of
Catch-22 right where it's like well you
need you need a job to have experience
but you kind of need to you sort of
already made experience to get a job uh
so the Capstone project is kind of the
thing that fixes that Catch-22 right it
kind of gives you
um that experience that you can
demonstrate to an employer and say look
like I did this thing I achieved this
thing uh it especially helps I will say
if you not just like talk about it or
show it to that like you know kind of
write that you did it on your resume but
if you actually open source your code
repository right so you should be doing
some kind of Version Control on your
code
hopefully that goes without saying
um so you'd have it on GitHub or
something like that if you open source
your GitHub and you can actually even
send them a link or even have a link in
your resume of like look here's my
GitHub here's where I coded all this up
here's where I here's where I did all
this stuff uh and then
uh you know that person can actually go
look at your GitHub and actually go look
at your code and look at how you did be
like oh wow this person actually like
knows how to do this stuff uh that can
really go a long way
thank you so much for asking that I
think someone there has awesome
so uh Capstone does act as a basically
work in your portfolio when you're
basically trying to look for a job also
uh I I'm not sure like if I understood
this that captured is as if you do an
internship at a company
so I can see one coming here yeah so
that it definitely is pretty similar
um so
yeah if you had an internship at a
company ultimately the one slight bit of
edge you'd have there is you'd have a
supervisor that could like write you a
letter of recommendation or like that
they could call and he'd be like yeah
that person was great you know but uh
um with a you know project and a thing
like this you technically don't have
that you technically don't have that
supervisor but yeah it is it is a lot
like that it's a lot like an internship
project where you can kind of
demonstrate like yeah I got this done
um and again uh the more transparent
that you can be about it right like
here's my code base you can go check
this out right like the the better off
you're going to be
um and it also demonstrates to them
things that are like hard to detect on
uh on a resume like if you have a really
good readme file uh all these things
that are sort of like not code but
they're like repository hygiene things
right like the better you can be about
that like I would be pretty impressed by
that actually because uh usually newbie
coders are terrible at that kind of
thing so if you can demonstrate that
actually you've done a great job at that
kind of stuff all right I'll give this
guy a shot so yeah
so thank you so much uh so I can see
that uh was trying to add what you were
trying to describe earlier so I think I
forgot to add that uh so I thought that
is a question so awesome uh also we'll
be talking about singular Community uh
which basically supports you as a
learner you make an access to
instructors program manager corporate
manager and also you'll be getting
access to learning teams and peers uh
for live interaction as well uh also a
curriculum resources which you can find
in the learning environment which we'll
be talking about more much in the
details so you get an idea how it's
acting the learning environment looks
like so Germany will be taking us
through the learning environment uh in
which we will be including how you can
manage a curriculum how where you can
access your life what's your classroom
where are the tests and assessments you
can find uh what are the labs and
projects which we have talked about
three of them but how you can access
them and where to find them how does it
work in the learning environment also
the caption project overview as well uh
once you've done with the program uh how
basically you can track your progress uh
and you can unlock your certificate as
well and are you only getting access to
support tools and also support from
which will be available 24 7. so
generally can you take us to the
learning environment
yeah happy too
um let's see let me I guess share my
screen real quick
um do you want me to just walk you
through the LMS the learning management
system
all right here let's see
so let me go ahead and share
oh whoops
let's see
let me make sure that worked yeah okay
good
okay so actually let me check can
everybody see my screen uh right now
I'm looking at my sort of dashboard in
the learning management system
okay good so
basically uh any uh kind of boot camp or
program that you'll have will be sort of
the first thing that's visible here so
uh we can click go to program
uh you can see here we have courses uh
so actually you also have prerequisites
here so if you need like a refresher on
programming or any of the mathematics
you can cover that stuff uh you have
your core courses here uh so these are
the courses that the cohort that I've
been teaching have gone through so uh
their introductory one intro to
artificial intelligence python for data
science
uh applied data science with python then
we got into kind of our
more proper uh Deep dive into machine
learning uh this then ultimately kind of
expanded into this is the course that
we're on right now
um so deep learning with Keras and
tensorflow uh which really is sort of
the current
go-to uh sort of tool kit uh in industry
for that kind of stuff and then uh next
we'll be getting into advanced deep
learning and computer vision and then
finally they'll have their Capstone
and I did mention we have other things
like electives
that you can kind of get into so if you
have
uh you know if you especially are
interested in the statistics or natural
language processing and speech you can
get into that reinforcement learning so
this is kind of like how
models learn from feedback uh this is
stuff that's relevant in things like
gaming so like you know video game AI or
um
robotics
um algorithmic trading this is actually
really really big right you kind of have
to give your model some sort of uh
reward for making money but also some
notion of like regret if it loses money
um so you know you kind of have to have
it learn like what kinds of actions
actually uh give it the reward that it's
after sort of uh essentially it maximize
its objective function uh then we get
into yeah the sort of artificial
intelligence uh master class so these
are all sort of options in the electives
and then ultimately
you get your certificate which I don't
know for some reason it actually treats
me like a student sometimes so
my certificate's locked sadly uh sad
trombone
um so if we go back to
my courses here
I'll show you guys what it was what this
would look like in a particular class
so you do have some self-learning here
which has different
videos that you can watch so this would
give you uh you know all kinds of things
that you can
sort of study on your own I do highly
recommend that you go through kind of
the relevant you know self-learning
um
while you are you know or kind of prior
to let me make sure I'm in the right
course actually
there we go
uh so I do recommend that you go through
the self-learning kind of prior to the
actual kind of lecture or the live class
then we have
um
the actual live classes that occur here
you can see that sometimes we have them
canceled so I was attending an event on
this weekend of the 12th and 13th
then we have Labor Day weekend coming up
so obviously we're not going to have
class there
but basically up to a half an hour
before when class is scheduled to start
there's sort of a like attend class
button that shows up here
so you can actually click on that
that gets you into the live session
then we have these different assessments
here so
you have
different data sets different you know
the things that you're going to kind of
work on here is sort of these
assessments as we go through the class
then in here we have our practice lab
environment which will take just a
second to boot up but I'll show you guys
what this looks like
so this is where I'll actually kind of
demonstrate
you know so once we've kind of talked
about the theory then it's like okay
let's see how this actually looks you
know in you know kind of a Hands-On kind
of coding sort of thing
so we'll actually code this up
uh yeah actually this notebook here so
I'll show you guys we'll kind of make it
a little bit bigger
so this is actually
code that will uh
build
a
deep feed forward artificial neural
network so this will take an arbitrary
architecture so this can have as many
hidden layers as you'd like with as many
neurons in those hidden layers uh so all
this stuff is sort of so we have our
Imports here we have our activation
functions uh which have to be applied to
each layer we have our objective
functions for both regression and
classification
we have our metrics to measure sort of
our goodness of fit or kind of our model
performance here
uh we have this one hot encoding
function that's like a necessary
processing function
and then ultimately all of this in this
one big block is the
code but I I actually rather than kind
of just like you know
putting this on screen in front of the
class and just being like there you go
read it like I actually did kind of like
code this up live in front of them and
talk them through like what does each
line do
uh yeah so to make sure it's as
instructive as possible uh and so that
they understand the logic and so that
they understand very very well or very
clearly like
how does the theory that we just covered
like how does the mathematics and the
theory that we covered actually
translate directly to code so uh we
actually do kind of see how this looks
when it actually gets applied
then once we had uh have this model
definition built uh just to show them
kind of what this looks like or how this
works uh simulated a data set for
classification so you can see here we
have the three different classes we'd
like the model to figure out how to
classify these
so with this one we construct or we
actually sort of call The Constructor
for the model to make an instance of the
model here that's what this little
lowercase a n n is
so you can see for this one
we have that this has three hidden
layers each hidden layer has 16 neurons
and then the rectified linear unit is
the activation that's going to be
applied at each hidden layer so then we
go ahead and fit the model to the data
with this line of code I do this show
curve equals true to actually have it
show the training curve so this is this
curve would represent our model's error
with each apoc of training so you can
see that as we train more we get less
and less error and that it converges to
a minimum
so then at the end we check what's our
accuracy so we're achieving a 97.5
percent accuracy on this simulated data
set which is pretty darn good
um
and then this final visualization here
visualize the actual kind of learned
decision boundary uh with the original
data set sort of overlaid on top of it
so you can kind of see what that looks
like
so that's a classification example
then we went ahead and simulated a data
set for a regression problem and I
actually kind of purposefully chose this
one so I kind of like created this uh
function so that our data would have
this little dip off of the trend
and I did that very very on purpose
because that's actually a thing that's
like really challenging actually for
machine learning models to learn so I
really wanted to kind of give our model
this challenge you know and not just
throw something easy at it
so then with this one uh
yeah actually because my uh
one of my students noted that we kept
using powers of two
uh for the neurons here so I wanted to
show that actually it didn't have to be
that way so we have uh let's see where
is it again so three hidden layers each
with 11 neurons which is actually like a
prime number
I have neurons so just it's just a
really show like this this would work
either way uh we this is very common
activation function so hyperbolic
tangent is the activation function being
applied to each hidden layer here
um again we show our training curve uh
and you can see I mentioned that this is
like a really big challenge for a model
and you can see that this indeed was uh
took us half a million
apocs of training to get this model
trained but ultimately you can see that
uh it did very very well so if we look
at our r squared metric which tells us
how much of the variance in the Target
is explained by our model we get an r
squared of 0.9874 so we're explaining a
little over 98.7 percent of the variance
in the target with our model and then
when we actually look at our model's
curve versus the data it fits very very
nicely so
um
so yep so this kind of shows
uh how this model kind of like looks in
action uh it just kind of kind of
happens or happened by accident that I
chose
uh to use three hidden layers with each
of these that doesn't have to be that
way this is kind of
what I did I guess so
um so yep this was an actual notebook
that we like coded up live in class uh
this last weekend
then we have this community portion here
so if we click on this community thing
here
this is where like students would uh ask
questions and I would answer them but
also I post stuff
from class here so you can see
uh this feed forward artificial neural
network notebook
um that I just barely showed you guys so
I encourage the students to really code
along uh you know to kind of be coding
it up as I'm coding it up
but uh just for a reference if anyone
needs it right posted this here on the
community thread so that others you know
basically any students who need it in
the class can download it and Tinker
with it
um ultimately then
so I did try this on like toy data right
on like simulated data that I just came
up with but you can see here we have
other data sets so like mnist very
important Benchmark data set uh where
we're doing sort of a computer vision
task well not sort of it is a it is a
computer vision task
um
where we're recognizing handwritten
digits and identifying what the actual
digit is that was that was written so
now we have this data set here that uh
kind of equipped with this notebook and
with this implementation of the model
students can kind of go away and Tinker
with this as well and kind of you know
uh get a feel for uh tuning all the
different hyper parameters so like how
many apocs of training uh what's our
learning rate uh up here you can see
other things like and against I don't
expect you guys to know exactly what
this means now but there are techniques
called regularization uh for machine
learning so we have these Lambda 1 and
Lambda 2 parameters uh for applying
different types of regularization and
kind of like the size of this parameter
sort of dictates like how much of this
regularization is applied to the model
so they can really kind of like
get a feel for fine-tuning all of those
hyper parameters as they fit this model
to that data set and see what kind of
you know results or accuracy they're
able to achieve there so
um yeah so you kind of get some some
Hands-On uh experience with that and
again actually probably like really
satisfying as well uh for those of those
students who
kept up with the actual coding live in
class uh you know to achieve a great
result on a data set like that with a
model that you coded up yourself uh yeah
it's really really fun uh and then
finally
you have your certificate and mine is
locked because I
because I have not uh completed the
class so uh but once you're done then
this year certificate actually for this
class uh shows up right so you can
actually kind of like as you're
progressing through this program if
you'd like if you'd like to kind of like
share these certificates on your
LinkedIn profile or whatever then you're
able to kind of display those as well as
you kind of get through this class by
class and then finally you know your
your big
uh ultimate program certificate shows up
here as well when you're done with all
of the uh the courses so
and that is I believe our yeah you can
get to the community here as well
um I think that's everything you guys
need to know about the learning
management system
so
cool so that's it
um
let me just quickly share my screen
yeah I hope my screen is
so moving forward uh we have Global
program readers as program advisors
uh who is the Karate CDMA executive
director and the global leaders from
Child tech make sure that simply learn
is delivering you know as per the
standards uh and also we'll be talking
about the learner outcomes so the
interesting thing about learning organs
is that the previous classes have
consisted of Learners from World Class
organizations and diverse Industries so
uh Learners are coming from Information
Technology bfsi software product farmer
Healthcare readings and others and also
organization slide Amazon e-wide
Vodafone Infosys New Media and essential
and PCs and many more
also uh you get
um a career as a Services by simply
known as well which helps you uh when
you are searching for a job once you're
done with the courses where uh so you
get access to a job Horton in this
particular career as a service uh
through resume and also you get a resume
review and rewrite service from Top
consuming and uh while you're preparing
for an interview we make sure that you
get a one-around interview service from
the top interview as well so that covers
everything uh when you are actually
trying to look for a job as well so
would love to know uh like your
questions if you have any questions
about the program please do put down
those questions that you will be taking
these questions I think someone asked
about the program fee as well so the
program fee which I've mentioned before
as well is eight thousand dollars and uh
I have seen a few questions about the
financing options available as well so
we have a financing offshore level uh as
low as seven seven hundred four dollars
per month and in case you have any more
questions related to the program you can
always
would you like to enroll in this program
you can see a quick hole on your screen
right now
so would you like to include in caltex
data analytics bootcamp would love to
know your interests
so we can reach out to you accordingly
you can see a quick call on your screen
uh would you like to enroll in the data
and using boot camp program by traffic
so you can see a quick quote on your
screen you can just select yes
and you can share your interest there so
are you interested in enrolling the
program
meanwhile uh just to let you know that
we'll be taking Q any questions uh very
soon the start of this and we've gotten
a lot of interesting questions in the Q
a box while you folks are voting in for
the call so we are very excited to take
those questions as well
um
okay I can see the poster moving in so I
would love to know would you like to
enjoying this program
you can see a quick pull in the screen
so I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds and we have five seconds more uh
to the folks few folks who have not
voted yet sharing their invest I can see
uh a lot of interest in enrolling the
program like folks are very much
interested in thinking of this data and
this book can close by contact
so I can see that those results so I'll
be closing the poll in five seconds so
five four three two one let me in the
poll
so we can see almost more than 70 of the
folks are interested in including the
program thank you so much for watching
now uh let me take you through the
enrollment steps uh for enrolling into
the program uh there are very simple 3D
steps you need to follow you need to
submit an application to us you can
apply at ask us at supreme.net
um the Catholic CTN we will review uh
based on the qualifications which we
have shared earlier and once your
application is debuted you will be
getting an admission call uh from that
learning Consultants from Simply learn
uh with an ambition offer so these are
the three simple steps for enrollment uh
also uh we have uh the next upcoming uh
on 20th November and the induction for
this is also on regular normal uh so as
I said we have limited seats uh only 25
to 30 Learners we take uh per program so
make sure that if you want to take up
this particular board so uh help me
answer this question but how soon do you
plan to enroll so let me just
quickly
launch the code so yeah you can see the
quick poll on your screen how soon do
you plan to enroll uh in the data index
boot camp by cardiac so you can choose
uh your option which is okay before you
if you're looking for immediately you
can choose the first one
if you're looking for weapon three
months you can choose the second one
if you're looking within six months you
can choose the third one
if you're looking for more than six
months from now still thinking about it
you can choose the first one
audience here who has basically a lot of
interest towards the data analytics boot
camp so I can see that interest
especially for the folks who have
already uh shared that they want to
enjoy this program I would recommend
changing when do you want to end also we
will have understanding when we can
reach out to you as well you know with
the details to take you through the
program in much more detail or any
questions you have related to the
programming
we'll be taking the Q a questions
after this so uh if you have any
questions if you've already voted uh for
the poll uh when do you plan to enroll
you can immediately go and put down your
questions you have in the Q a box
because we'll be taking the community
questions post yesterday
I'll be closing the poll in 10 seconds
uh we'll give five more seconds so five
four three two one
so I can see
um for most of the folks wants to join
immediately and we can see like how the
folks actually want to run the agreement
so we have upcoming like comments as
well after that so that's great
now let's move on to the Q a section so
uh I think we'll start with
um
okay uh let us take
I think we have taken a question from uh
what practical skills do you need
okay I think we'll take one uh question
from how does your data Antics move down
uniquely positioned graduates to stand
out and secure talk to your applications
yeah so
um
if you're a recent graduate
here's kind of an interesting thing that
I experienced when I graduated so I
graduated with a degree in mathematics
and
uh got a job actually uh with uh with
Honeywell actually is a data analyst
um went in and immediately was like oh
my gosh I have no idea what I'm doing
which was surprising because you know
it's like I went from having like
basically a 4-0 GPA in mathematics uh to
then getting into this data analytics
environment and I had even taught like a
lab at the University of Arizona
um on uh statistics and probability and
on data mining with r and all this kind
of stuff so I'm like I've already like
taught classes at a university on uh
analytics and all that kind of stuff but
then found myself in the actual like
work environment and project environment
and immediately felt like a fish out of
water like I just immediately felt like
I did not know I was not not gonna be
able to cut it
um
so
yeah college is great it gives you a lot
of like really great skills that
ultimately you need to develop the
skills that you need to succeed
in the workplace uh so it's like there's
kind of this gap between like right when
you get out of school and like where you
actually need to be uh in your first job
and so if you're looking to land in like
a data science or data analytics job
this boot camp is actually kind of that
bridge that sort of crosses that gap for
you right or that gets you across that
Gap right so you'll actually get some uh
actual exposure to like uh what does it
look like to do a data project right
like how do you actually code this stuff
up how do you Wrangle the data
um
and uh yeah I'm pretty sure
most if not all of our instructors are
actually people like me
who don't just teach uh you know we're
actually in industry
actually doing this stuff like real real
stuff with uh real clients with real
data
so
um
yeah I don't know how much the other
teachers like to do this but uh as much
as possible as I'm teaching as we're
covering a topic
um I will give as many examples as come
to mind basically of like how this ties
back to an actual thing I've seen in
Project right where it's like this came
up you know this this stakeholder
thought this or they wanted this here's
what we saw in the data like here's what
we needed to deliver
um so that as much as possible we can
kind of like
basically share our experience with you
of what it's actually like to be on
Project you know with a client doing
this kind of stuff uh so that it's not
just some like you know Ivory Tower you
know Theory kind of kind of stuff like
we actually do want you guys to kind of
get a real feel for like what is it like
to do this in the real world right
awesome thank you so much
I hope that answers your question please
let us know on the chat I can see one
question from akivo I have been teaching
data mining ml uh DL and DW
visualization for almost two years and
having a Passion to work in industry but
I've been applying for that but I've
always been rejected because I have a
PhD what can you give me as an advice to
me
let's see okay so you've been rejected
because you have a PhD or because you
don't have a PhD because it seems like a
person having a PhD is never a reason to
not hire them
um
so yeah I I would say so I guess I'll
just I'll just kind of uh go with your
question as it's written here
um
yeah I I don't think you're you know
being rejected has anything to do with
having a PhD or not having a PhD
um
It ultimately just kind of comes down to
what can you do what can you get done
this actually does remind me of a
project that I was on again back to my
time at Promontory Financial Group uh we
were doing a project with Union bank and
we were going through the horrendous
effort of uh getting all of their
procurement data together so that we
could basically do a spend analysis
right so their spend was on the order of
like 14 billion annually
um and I mean you know they're like
probably any company right very
inefficient with their spending uh it's
too big for everyone to really have an
eye on everything that's going on
uh they also kind of made a very common
mistake which is you get most companies
that get big get big by acquiring
smaller competitors and then what
happens is uh you've acquired some
smaller company they have completely
different software for things like their
general ledger their accounts payable
all that kind of stuff but you're just
kind of like ah it's fine
and you don't really make them
assimilate into the mothership and so
then what happens is you do enough of
that and now all of a sudden you have
all these different branches and regions
that all have completely different
looking accounts receivable accounts
payable
their like General ledge
hierarchy is totally different they
don't have like the same like taxonomy
of their spend and so somehow all of
this has to be unified so that like the
executive team can actually have a sense
for like what spending looks like right
so
just let me tell you it's a mess to do
all of that stuff or to get all that
stuff together that's like 80 of the job
and any spend analysis is just getting
their stuff like cleaned up so you can
even look at it
um
around that time we added a member to
our team uh who had a PhD in statistics
from University of Minnesota uh
uh who shall remain nameless let's just
call him John uh and uh he was supposed
to jump in on this spend analysis part
because that was just part of what we
were doing for Union Bank
um
so John was supposed to be helping me
with this sort of like data crunching
you know stuff
um
basically what happened is he spent
about four weeks
achieving absolutely nothing and every
time that we had a meeting there was
some kind of like different excuse of
like oh like uh you know my computer you
know uh got bricked I got some kind of
malware I had to send it back into
corporate you know whatever because we
were all remote
so
uh the guy who was our director of
analytics had about a week that he was
out uh you know he was actually like on
site speaking to somebody with Union
Bank was a little bit you know kind of
Off the Grid we couldn't really
communicate with him
he came back uh after a week of being
gone we were
um presenting what we had done like kind
of what progress we had made so far uh
in the week that he was out and John
basically had nothing to show like so
the the guy who was our director
basically kind of pointed out he's like
Jeremy I realized that like it kind of
seems like you're doing an awful lot of
the talking here uh John do you have
anything you want to add to this
um and again John was just kind of like
oh yeah I honestly I didn't really get
anything done this last week I had to
send my computer and whatever so uh the
the director was like okay well thank
you very much uh Jeremy great job uh
we'll go ahead and call the meeting
there John could you stay on for another
minute which is like the most ominous
thing ever like I was like right like to
this day I feel this like deep like
cringe in my soul for John about this
um and uh I never saw John again so
uh basically
he and I were like kind of talking at
some point uh during this whole project
and I was kind of like he he had some
questions I was helping him answer the
questions connections he wasn't able to
make with like the general ledger and
accounts payable and all that kind of
stuff and he literally was just like I
have never seen data like this before
he was like this is so messy this is
just like so much work I like there's
all this like manipulation I have to do
like I have never seen this before ever
uh and I was a little bit baffled by
that because I was like dude it is
always like this so that's maybe kind of
the one thing I think that's uh that's
maybe sort of a disservice that's done
to you if you have been in a PhD kind of
environment you've been in that kind of
academic environment and then you want
to make the leap to like the you know to
Industry
um
where a lot of the stuff a lot of the
data sets that you're going to work with
in like a university environment or an
academic environment are like highly
curated highly polished uh basically
tailor-made for like seamless you know
uh integration with machine learning and
all that kind of stuff and then you may
kind of get used to working with stuff
like that and think oh I'm like the king
of the world I can go do it go through
the stuff anywhere and then you go join
a company and have to do this like for a
real client that has real data that's
really really messy and it's going to be
a real shock so that's maybe kind of the
one thing that I kind of would uh kind
of cite about that if you're kind of
maybe coming from a PhD environment and
that's problematic for any interviewers
that uh that you've talked to that could
be it you may want to actually give
yourself a chance to go uh go work with
some really really messy data somewhere
like uh
I don't know I don't know what county
you live in but see if you can locate
your like tax assessment database and go
download that
go see go see if you can download your
like your local tax assessment database
and reconstruct it and that'll give you
a real appreciation for like what
happens in like a real project so
uh I think we should definitely have a
lot to learn from John thank you so much
for sharing certificate story uh from
your experience uh so now I hope that
answers your question about that
healthier will just known chat here so
we have one more question uh the name is
not mentioned here so I'm a product
manager that needs to get good data
analytics saving especially in terms of
software tools uh does the Celtic
bootcamp makes sense for me or would it
make more sense to get focused on
learning specific software like family
Etc uh do I need a super deep dive or
should I just leverage existing tools
so that's an excellent question
um it may be hard for me to answer
for your specific use case but I will
tell you this in the cohort that I'm
currently teaching about 60 of my
students are actually in that kind of
position right so I was I kind of came
into this expecting
that a lot of the students would be like
recent graduates maybe people that have
been like software Engineers for a
couple years and decided that they
wanted to kind of make the switch over
to data science uh and there are those
people there are those students for sure
um but very much my surprise yeah like
over half of my students are like yeah
I'm the CTO of this company or you know
I'm head of engineering at meta like
that person is in my class like
right like uh you know and they're kind
of like hey I'm you know I'm supervising
this team of like 10 data scientists I
have no idea what they do right I have
absolutely no idea what they're up to
day in and day out I would really really
like to get a sense for like what does
data science look like what are these
guys actually dealing with what are
their challenges what kind of tools
should they be using all that kind of
stuff so if that is
uh if that is your your kind of vantage
point of like like I manage a bunch of
data scientists and I have no idea what
data science really is uh I think this
makes perfect sense for you because
that's over half the people that I have
at my cohort
I hope
I hope it's anybody you have that
question
how more questions we have gotten in
here okay uh I think this is a very
common question uh we're getting from a
lot of folks uh what advice would you
give to a data and you think special who
is just starting out
let's see
uh what advice would you give to a
student who's just starting out
uh okay I would say thinking back
I would read a lot uh that's
advice uh learn any way that you can
learn as much as possible
um
because I think the landscape of data
science and analytics is ever changing
it's ever evolving sometimes I think it
changes a little too fast uh to be
honest so last year in 2022
there was kind of this like new
development I think that was becoming a
very big part of the conversation was
knowledge graphs uh which I think
knowledge graphs are actually still
absolutely phenomenal and the thing that
is uh definitely going to be very very
important for the future of a lot of
applications in data science and machine
learning
but just as knowledge graphs we're
starting kind of starting to catch on
and become like as soon as there was
starting to be any kind of like
attention paid to this conversation
around knowledge graphs November 2022
happens
uh open AI turns on chat GPT uh and now
almost no one talks about knowledge
graphs because now all anyone can talk
about is large language models right
um so it's like things shift really
quickly things move really really
quickly and there are always new things
to learn
that being said I also would advise that
you not get kind of like
you know kind of the whipla Whiplash
that
could happen if you're kind of like
always just watching for stuff that's on
the edge
um ultimately
what you really should kind of secure
first is like this very very strong
knowledge of the fundamentals right I
mean data science is like anything it's
like basketball or you know swimming or
whatever right like if you have strong
fundamentals that's really going to kind
of
um
you know kind of determine the ultimate
like height of your sort of Arc in that
thing
so
yeah again going back to that other
slide that talked about linear
regression and logistic regression
like make absolutely sure that you know
those things inside and out that you
know those two algorithms like frontward
and backwards inside you know every
which way
because actually everything comes back
to them right uh you know if we're
talking about like uh there are all
kinds of things that actually just work
from just generalized linear modeling so
that in and of itself is actually an
extremely useful and quite vast body of
knowledge like I said linear and
logistic regression are the basis for
all deep learning uh because feed
forward neural networks are basically
constructed from them and then any other
architect or architecture going forward
is ultimately built from a feed forward
neural network
um in Time series modeling things like
Auto regressive models like arima
uh essentially what you do is you
perform enough Transformations on the
data that the assumptions of linear
regression become somewhat valid and
then you fit linear regression to it uh
so it's something that comes into play
there
um and a big thing for me right now
at Equifax so our like legal and privacy
team actually just gave us approval that
we can start using neural networks for
uh modeling fraud and things like that
um the reason why we were so restricted
before is because of regulatory reasons
right under the Fair Credit Reporting
Act if ultimately we give guidance that
someone should not be approved for a
loan they have a right to come back
under the Fair Credit Reporting Act and
say like well why didn't I get it and we
can't just be like well the magical
algorithm just said you can't have a
loan right like we have to be able to
explain our model outputs so
uh
deep learning models have kind of
historically been known as these like
black box models that are unexplainable
uh but there actually are a lot of
breakthroughs that are being made in
that space as well sort of explaining uh
supposedly Black Box Ai and uh the sort
of front runner right now in that space
is this algorithm called chap
uh because it's based on shapley values
from Game Theory anyway
um
shop is ultimately linear regression
like you basically come up with this
like modified version of your model and
its inputs so that you can ultimately
put them into a linear regression and
explain them that way uh so it's like
everything even the stuff that seems
completely on the edge completely you
know like on the bleeding edge of all
this stuff like in some way I'm telling
you just about everything like basically
ties back to linear regression so like
there is a core and I would strongly
strongly strongly recommend that you
like learn that core very very well and
that would be yeah that's the main main
thing that would be like my my main
advice to anybody who's just starting
out
oh thank you so much
such a quick experience
just last question uh I'm so sorry we
have extended the program by 30 minutes
but if this is the last question we are
getting more questions but we'll just
close after this uh so sorry folks so as
a fresher a fresh graduate looking to
specialize in details I'm Keen to
explore different domains analysis plays
a crucial role uh could you provide
insights into the key Industries or
domains that your organizations State
art exchange is involved in
understanding this would help me better
align my skills and interest and
potential areas of contribution
all right that's a great question so
let's see so
uh so key Industries
uh um oh that my analytics team is
involved in so uh I'm everywhere
[Music]
uh so yeah so we have Equifax where uh
very directly involved with detecting
Financial crime that you guys have
already heard about another client of
mine is a company called espritas here
in Atlanta uh they're in the compressed
gas industry so if you think about
uh like food grade and beverage grade
CO2 for like restaurants that have like
you know fountain soda uh medical grade
nitrous oxide and oxygen for clinics and
dentists offices uh acetylene
uh butane all this kind of stuff for
welding and Industrial applications and
then also there are tons and tons of
applications for like propane
specifically so they're all about kind
of unifying the supply chain in that
space is what espritas is about so I'm
doing a ton of like supply chain
analytics in that space and kind of like
sourcing Matrix optimization
um
what are called things that are called
survival modeling uh so like
any time that you're predicting a
duration where you want you kind of like
have a well-defined beginning and then
there's a well-defined event that you're
waiting for and you want to predict on
like what is the sort of like you know
estimated duration until that thing
happens it's called survival modeling uh
I'm doing tons of survival modeling so
like once a customer orders given what
they've ordered or what kind of customer
they are and a few other things like how
long do we think it'll be until they
would need to place another order uh so
we can kind of anticipate that
um
but I've done algorithmic trading I've
done spend analytics for organizations
that need to get their spend under
control which is actually basically
every organization uh done
um throughput optimization for hospitals
uh things like linear programming for
optimizing like nursing staff scheduling
um I mean frankly to it would be faster
to tell you what industries are
currently not using data and analytics
uh
which I don't think is any of them
I think basically everybody if you're in
energy uh if you're in banking or
Finance or any kind of financial
services uh real estate a lot of
analytics happening in real estate these
days that's actually one of the ones
that's hardest though because again sort
of the gatekeeper thing The Association
of Realtors kind of a big gatekeeper in
that space because they sort of have
this like Monopoly on all listing data
which sucks
um
but uh yeah I mean basically like you
can kind of go anywhere and do anything
and I think that's actually a real power
for data scientists and for machine
learning as a discipline
it's kind of a thing that we seek to do
in any mathematics is you kind of take
any sort of technique or method and kind
of abstract it away from the like
specific real world application which
allows you to kind of you know it makes
it more portable and you can kind of
take it anywhere and solve all kinds of
stuff uh so as far as a machine learning
algorithm is concerned if you're trying
to predict like a house price or you
know a stock price or uh like where a
pallet should go in a warehouse a
machine learning model doesn't know what
a palette is or what a house is or what
stock is it doesn't know any of that as
far as it's concerned the only thing
you're showing it is a vector so as long
as you can come up with some kind of
vector representation of whatever it is
you're trying to model uh you can apply
machine learning to it so
uh yeah basically any of the techniques
that you would learn linear regression
logistic regression deep learning any of
that stuff is 100 portable to basically
any industry application that you you
can think of so
thank you so much for answering that
question one last question and I hope
that answers is your question now for
folks who have already shared their
interest in enrolling internal program I
would like to know if you need any
assistance in enrolling into the caltex
data and Facebook channel so I would
highly recommend yes why not take the
you know extra help you're getting away
uh in order to understand the program
writer so you can see a quick one on the
screen uh if you've shared an interest
in enrolling into the program uh you can
select uh yes uh if you need assistance
in enrolling into the program so uh you
can just quickly go and go for the
folder on the screen and uh yeah
I'll be giving 15 seconds uh for this
role and uh meanwhile let me see if we
have any any questions about okay
okay I can see the pose are still moving
so uh most of the folks have already
voted share their interests uh in
getting the assistance to enroll into
the caltex data analytics boot camp uh
so you can just see a quick one on the
screen uh go and quickly vote uh if
you're interested uh in getting the
assistance from Simply learn uh in
enrolling to the caltex leadership
okay I'll be closing the hole in five
seconds so if the folks who have not
voted so five
four three
two one
thank you so much uh for sharing your
response uh I we're towards the end of
the session now uh thank you so much
Journey for joining us and taking us to
the Catholics data index boot camp and
also uh introduce introducing us to John
that was an interesting one uh and uh
would you like to say something about
audience before we close the session
sorry what was the last part would you
like to see something in the audience
before we close the history
oh um
yeah just uh I guess thanks everybody
for your time uh thanks for listening to
all my my War Stories
about my time in Industry
um hopefully this was helpful
um and uh yeah hopefully uh we'll see
you guys in an upcoming cohort I know
that you guys actually uh if you would
like uh you can actually request uh to
be in a cohort with me if that's
something that would be appealing to you
I know that uh
uh the cohort that I actually started
with I was just going to teach them for
like one class uh and then they actually
requested that I actually that they do
the rest of the cohort with me so I
don't know if it's typical for
instructors to go through an entire
cohort or an entire like sort of like
program with one cohort but uh that's
what they requested so
um yeah that's the thing that like if
you're kind of like hey this Jeremy guy
seems okay which hopefully you think
that
then uh yeah I think you could even you
know kind of mention that or uh request
to to do that and uh I'll also to I
should also say all of our instructors
are pretty great though so uh you know
so if you don't like me there's probably
somebody else that you will that you
will like I'm sure that is an
interesting
[Music]
if it is yours so I can I can I can
assure you folks here so because you
basically we've gotten to know a lot of
interesting stuff about you so yeah uh
so we'll be closing the session also
thank you everyone for joining thank you
once again
and uh have a good night good evening
good morning you know very joining film
thank you so much folks
thanks guys see ya